good morning Millennials have to finish
chewing sorry Snickers that I brought
you 20 minutes ago and you decide to eat
20 seconds ago I'm just trying to be
good look no I'm not gonna have a
Snickers first thing in the morning
let me just sat there and I was like
okay and sometimes you need a hit of
sugar to get through the day and to get
through the most premium morning show
I'm so happy to have you back meet you
oh my god I watched a little bit of Ben
I always get like an infuriated watching
but specifically with Ben because I
disagree with everything he says so I
turn it off but I watch tellers tracker
cuz like I felt like I was watching you
and I for sure it's interesting thing
about tailors checker is like she and I
just like our Santa highly polar
opposites have so many issues so many TV
shows i watch like 40 minutes and then i
had to get off the train
do you guys to talk about Bethenny no
because she told me she was seen Carrie
I know you must have late intercourse so
I didn't feel the need to kick it at
Plus Carole is off the show so you won
the war huh the war has been won the war
has been won welcome to the morning
shows the most prestigious morning show
where we support other female
entrepreneurs because me and Jackie were
was just talking about our outfits and
your shirt is XLE by Lauren Elizabeth
two shirts this week of hers got me a
beautiful care well yeah you nice and
got it for free I paid for this but it's
something Navy from Nordstrom and I just
have to say it is so true to size and
I'm so used to ordering for my cheap
websites where like I literally order
two sizes bigger like just so that it
fits loosely and I did that like I
ordered one size bigger and I'm like I
lost little weight so like it's like an
awkward time for me and it's so true
decides like I could have done a size
smaller it looks so good it's not crap
and so comfy and does not used to buy
not [ __ ] you know yeah bought me a
jacket from her collection together you
know I look forward to it it's like a
sky-blue trench coat very morning she
should at least a statement apologizing
no I don't follow her okay like
obviously as I've been like a shady way
no yeah she like released it and
everyone wanted to buy it obviously and
like it also down she literally broke
the Nordstrom's website I saw in People
magazine People magazine wrote and then
she like wrote up this apology based
literally like she murdered someone it's
like relax everyone wants about your
clothes Congrats like for sure a good
problem to have
yeah so people associated because they
at Lee when I was looking for stories
that morning they had like the story she
must have given them the exclusive but
her car came with you I'm like the line
is here that you've been waiting for and
then like five hours later it's like all
the all the
tweets about her siting down right it's
like I'm sorry but customer service
tweets are not a new story no totally
and also like that happens to everyone
like even Kylie right but and it's not a
negative it's not like it's not a
negative and may the best part that so
many people wanted to buy that she broke
by the way Nordstrom's website like if
they can't handle the truth if they
can't handle ecommerce like who can know
totally and what was so funny about that
article that was obviously associated
and whoever wrote it just like hated
Arielle but they were using affiliate
links so there was a disclaimer at the
top of this article that was like really
[ __ ] mean and they were like by the
way if you click on anything these links
we might make a make them am i kids
speak English
make a residual whatever affiliate
basically they link to her collection
they link to specific things and if you
clicked it which obviously a lot of
people did because it's people calm they
made money so they're like trashing her
but also like using her to make money
well thirsty is hell and by the way our
time so tough over there that you're
using affiliate links like some
low-level thirsty little bloggers hi I
use it go get links you shouldn't but
it's like crazy how little you make from
affiliate links so tension when people
buy stuff it's like 10 cents it's crazy
how was the rest of the commotion he's
Oh Tuesday we had a podcast only episode
uh which was nice except like it
definitely made my week this has been a
very long and hard week plus the UN
which I've been complaining about on
every episode huh um so it's been a
tumultuous week then came he was great
it's funny now we co-hosted so many
times together that like it's no longer
like special yeah the been like you've
never seen him before it's like did we
even make a guest card for him no it's I
get to work yeah totally roll up your
sleeves he was working hard for you and
then yesterday Taylor's trekker who I've
never co-hosted with before but who is
just a pro I couldn't agree more as much
as it's so hard to find a good co-host
it's like the ones who are good are
great and they make my job so she has so
much experience I'm like she doesn't
even like think about it anymore you
know yeah I love her I love her tail
definitely gonna call on her again
because you're a busy woman um wait we
me and Margo
we're in do you see obviously I mean I
went to bed before our flight like at
1:00 a.m. and we were like about to go
to sleep we're like swirling on our
phones and literally be both like gasp I
just got a notification from Dell so
it's like your flights been canceled go
[ __ ] yourself like that was it was just
so like
bye and then they're like well we'll
reschedule you and they were skilled
with me on like a three o'clock shuttle
whatever they put Margo on a 12 o'clock
flight that literally flew her like to
Paris and back and she got it at like 8
p.m. it was so stupid and like people
are so not Delta
it's so not DC because everyone was like
DC's a shadow hundred-hour I'm like
really where where the Acela is so DC so
then we were like alright well we're
obviously not gonna like be on different
flights and I'm not gonna spend more
money so Delta gave me a full refund in
their defense they didn't give me a
reason why I liked it was a perfectly
beautiful day like what was it and I
took the [ __ ] train which was
honestly lovely it's like would I rather
jour to do our three hours no matter if
you fly or if you've trained what I'd
rather just sit on a train for three
hours or like an hour in the airport and
I were on the plane an hour back I think
I would rather sit on the train except
me and Margo since I got a full refund
and I sprung for the business class
Accela we got there like 10 minutes
before the train took off and it was I
completely feel like all these loser
politicians I got there an hour before
so me to sit in the quiet car and like
people take that [ __ ] so seriously you
can't talk on the phone me and I
couldn't talk to each other oh my god
and like you know when there's like two
seats facing each other and like a table
in between it's obviously felt like a
family and like one old man sits there
and ruins it for everyone so there were
two sets of four next to each other and
one old man in each so me and Margaret
just separate and sit with our like our
sugar daddies did you make any friends
make any connections actually did this
guy was really cute and he didn't speak
a lot of English and he just wants to
know what time it was and I liked him
he's the French any more red suspenders
what's he important you know you look
around and you're like a cèlle do you
see like who do we got on here chris
Christie you know actually did see Chris
Christie on it on a train once oh I
thought you said on this trip notice
there's also first-class which was like
way too expensive
I'm sure Chris Christie was there even
though the more that I think about it
like if you're a politician you're like
a civil servant and you really should be
in coach for the rest of us but whatever
but whatever just saying um speaking of
comedy I saw Kevin Hart last night oh my
god I saw your Instagram story that was
like you're going to support another
homie well he is my second favorite
comic who's your first you know buddy's
like actually your first real favorite
no before my sister before comics but
like back in the day before I meant to
act like Kevin Hart was my dream yeah
and it was just when he was like dating
a Nico so I was like I
did have a chance yes I love him so much
like I by the way he's married too when
you come and you still have a chance
ja ja I truly want to marry him and like
I still do I like I don't know I just I
saw one thing that he was in once and I
just like fell in love with him and I
just became his biggest fan ever since
and now he's like in every movie so I
don't get a chance to get to every movie
but I was so excited to see I met Emma
she thank you to Live Nation for the
premium seats and it's so crazy so
because this stage is pretty de toll
they're able to fill it up with so many
seats it was the most people ever at
Madison Square Garden because he's also
the littlest and takes up the little is
about done staying but it was like this
little snot at little sage brain is
square so you're able to add all these
more seats on the floor that is probably
like and there's a moat of course and so
it was just so interesting the car it
was like there was not an empty seat in
the room and everybody loved him so much
and he's so cute and his said wasn't
like my favorite set he's ever done but
like he could literally just stand there
and I was like no he's the type of
person now that I'm like a comic and I
like read a lot about comics he's like a
physical comic in the sense that like he
could literally just like stand there
and talk about nothing but the way he
talks is funny
so you find everything he says funny
like it's so funny I just I was when he
came out on stage I was just like
smiling he is so hard cuz like I've very
limited performance and like playing in
a comedy club is the best because I get
to see people like they see your face
like seeing like probably seeing Kevin
Hart from like a mile away and thinking
he's still funny he's probably like the
hardest thing there's big TVs oh that's
true yeah really
oh yeah like a Jumbotron or whatever and
it's really crazy how crazy they are
about cell phones and recording like if
you even take your phone out they kick
you out one time when I went to Amy
Schumer at MSG I took a selfie and like
I got in trouble they didn't kick me out
but like here they start waving their
thing around and you are out like it's
so crazy they don't want anything leaked
but then it's like and Amy Schumer did
this too when I saw her at the Seaport
they use sets that they did on SNL
during their monologues there were a
couple jokes that I had already heard
and I like new air was going from SNL
it's like everyone who liked you watched
dressed in a monologue right repeating
jokes well I get the the first thing
about the phone cuz like hey if they're
recording it for a special like nobody
needs to watch it and be like if someone
literally puts like a two-minute video
that's like you're ruining someone
else's opportunity when they go I
completely
it was so nice to not be on my phone
completely and then at the end he was
like everyone take your phones out he's
like okay and start recording now we're
at Emma she oh that's so funny I mean I
was out the door by then I think she
brought up a seal or something but I
just see the wood again ninety thousand
people I didn't want to get no tribute
oh boy he told the story at the end
about seal that was like so funny he was
if we go to Aspen every year around the
holidays like his word the one black
family there and it's our black week in
Aspen and he was like and last year Neil
was there and I'm like to see like why
you ruining my back week he was like we
don't even know he's like we just like
only black people so then seal was like
I'm going up to this mountain and Kevin
like brought his whole family oh my god
that's so funny so many and then the
seal I guess came out and was there but
he is just so cute and it was just a
really nice night what do you think he
weighs like hundred fifty well he in his
in his promo package they call him the
little Hercules because he's so much he
said yeah it was like and if he was just
like an average height he'd be like most
built guy but then also the premise of
the tour it's called the irresponsible
tour because it's like his apology tour
for cheating on his wife oh right and so
he has to go into that a little and it's
like Kevin like we love you like I don't
care that you cheated on your wife
I fear that you're the highest-paid
comic right now in the industry if
you're not cheating on your wife like
who a right
no like it's definitely like a bad thing
I don't approve of it but like you don't
need to apologize to me like when at one
of my meet and greets anytime a boy
comes all he does is like yeah I heard
beg you want a KFC and then like so what
do you think about KFC and his wife I'm
like I don't know her and it's not my
business like if someone in the public
does something like that affects other
people like you need to apologize to her
but like your person life is your
personal life I'm like yes I think
you're disgusting but like right so I'm
not legal right I think it's weird when
people have Slyke issue apologies like
issue an apology to your wife or things
that you did in your personal life that
aren't crimes right
they KFC I thought that like it's it's
it's bad I don't approve but I also
don't care right it's none of my beeswax
yeah mind your own beeswax also speaking
of comics um I have a couple shows
coming up Buffalo and Albany this week
I'm hitting up the better you know
there's an Albany not all be there's an
upstate New York group and it's called
shook to the core of New York because
that's like a closed world yes
Albany Buffalo Albany I'm gonna be out
this weekend Buffalo - shows as well
and then I'm hitting Huntsville Alabama
which you've been talking about for a
very long time yeah you know there are
no jebecca flights which automatically
makes me hate Huntsville as a city but I
feel look past it um I think there's no
direct flights from Newark LaGuardia
okay Wow
yeah I got a stop in Atlanta but if you
fly Delta to Atlanta you automatically
get the best planes because the Delta
headquarters is in Atlanta so I kept I'm
in first class which because am i
standing in Delta I usually get upgraded
to I might even have a bed right there
are worse places to be than Atlanta no
totally I'm so Atlanta soon right yes oh
my god I'm like so excited about it cuz
like the when when we booked the show in
Boston it was like the biggest deal ever
and like it is but now Atlanta is also
like the same amount of people that
might even be more oh really
yeah maybe I should be going in the
Atlanta show not the Boston show
whatever you want but I want to meet the
boss scenes and we are the number one
podcast master oh oh so we have to
respect that show up well soon respect
the hell out of us therefore heretofore
we us in what else I really want to talk
about anything
I'd like the past five yet like know me
what else I haven't seen you in so I
know what else said it was just a fun
couple days we had nephews day and on
Tuesday oh yeah
which was just a beautiful day for me in
the tags yeah you were churning out
premium content and I find it very
difficult emotionally to look at
pictures or videos of Theo while I'm
like away cuz I feel so guilty but you
did a very good job of ensuring that he
was protected yeah at all course he
really does need protection at all costs
yeah I want to set someone up with my
dog walker like he's so hot he's in
money but are his stats
yeah well he so he's finishing undergrad
he's a little older cuz he was in the
Navy like he was busy like you know
protecting us and he's very smart goes
to an Ivy League school I don't give too
much away like and then maybe like I get
back to him goes to an Ivy League school
he is he was studying like something
very smart science but God offered a
wonderful job in finance and we'll be
taking that after he graduates and he's
just so handsome he was in the city Wow
okay not Jewish
line up yeah line em up light them up I
joined the Jew it for the toast subgroup
on facebook new favorites have actually
you added me yeah and I don't need as
many like I don't basically what it is
it's like a photo oriented group like if
you need anything you need help with a
caption a photo a Photoshop a filter a
preset and they're all like in have a
invested in presets I think you got
everyone a little crazy I did yeah and I
feel good about it and now we have a
hashtag gif tt champagne glass clinking
hashtag on Instagram if you use it and
then we'll all like your pictures that
you use using - it's so smart yeah
di ftt plantain emoji which emojis
contribute to the hash wave because
there were some other ones people using
okay so smart I'm gonna go like all them
yeah no it's so premium
that's my new favorite subgroup right
now yeah my new favorite subgroup is the
DMV toasters which is the DC and
surrounding areas because apparently DC
is near Virginia and Maryland and when I
got off the plane I saw a sign welcome
to Virginia Virginia is for lovers and I
was so [ __ ] confused and I was like
fully convinced that I got off the wrong
on the wrong plane and cuz I knew we
were like kind of close like Baltimore
and so it would make me send Maryland it
would have been left but I forget that
DC is like not a state like they don't
have their own Airport it's like a
district right I I don't know what the
correct answer is to where it's DC I
just know that it's Virginia and
Maryland DMV that's whatever's happening
yeah I don't know is it on the border is
it like should Jamie from watch remember
have gotten there and put her legs in
two places I hope so and so funny so I
had two shows on Wednesday night and
right before it was a 7 o'clock on a
9:30 and like literally at 6:59 when I'm
in the dressing room alone it's like the
one minute I got to myself and I'm like
crying and like I pray and like I talk
to myself in the mirror I got a text
from my friend Zack Eckstein from he was
a my grade of her mom's like such a nice
guy he was like oh my god I didn't know
he move to DC and he was like I'm gonna
no idea you were here I just tried to
get tickets to your show like you have
any extra I'd love to come to the 930
and like you join me when people text me
like being thirsty I'm like no please
but like I actually loved him and like I
think he sees really funny and like I
just wanted to see what like he would
think about my comic and apparently he
works for a senator like here's a
prestigious job and I think he's single
ladies um and he came and I was like
when I know that there are people in the
audience that I know personally like it
definitely affects me like at the first
show Ben's sister was there I'm like if
I talk about the guys good joke about
like hand jobs like it just like awkward
like you know and that's why like when
Ben's parents come like a really [ __ ]
with me and they like bring their
friends like it can't stop thinking
about like haircuts dad is here you know
what I mean like he's feeding my head
not with you guys so the good sisters
cuz like you know but like just other
people who might you could say
it's true but other people who like
might form an opinion and like who I met
when I could definitely [ __ ] some yet I
feel like my friend from high school
being there like really elevated me and
it was my greatest show yet
and the venue had a recording system
that they recorded it for me so now I
can like watch myself back and like
study which I really don't want to do
but I should yeah you know for sure I
was when I was now that my sister is a
big comic when I was watching Kevin Hart
last night I was just like thinking
about the art of comedy and it's really
like it's acting a lot because the big
cuz then I went back and watched his SNL
monologue to make sure and there's it
was actually really funny the bit that
he did I understand what he's SNL was
the best
oh no but his most recent one he talks
about how he just had a kid and he was
like women have so much patience with
the children it's really amazing but no
offense like you're not the fun parents
and when like the man gets home from
work and he's so tired and that babies
like let's play daddy Theo it's me with
counselors yeah totally and so I was
watching max I wanted to send it to
everybody no she's the thing is funny so
I forgot about it but anyways that was
like wow he's really acting because I
just saw this i right right wow this is
a college no yeah he's acting and that's
why when people come to me read
something like oh my god I saw you in
whatever and I'm like oh my god you know
I'm a fraud because like like I'm the
type of person we're like the reason I
never wanted to do stand-up was because
like I'm just funnier like we never
prepare like we just riff and that's
like my style and so I would say
probably like 40 percent of my shell
ways still like made up as I go but I
need to have some bones because I
couldn't eat something to talk about so
like there are a few jokes that
obviously like I repeated every show and
I just feel like a fraud when someone's
like I always tell you twice I'm like oh
my god no you know all my secrets but
every that's comedy yeah right well
right it's acting that's why so many
stand-up comics who like get really
popular to go into acting also my friend
from Colgate Caperton texted me she was
at your show she text me after she was
like it was a great show which one um DC
know which one there were three oh she
might have text me Wednesday night I
don't know okay no that's good I just
like to know cuz you know I took a three
weeks off for the holidays obviously and
so Tuesday night was like my first night
back and like I wasn't sure cuz I'm so
new to this if it's like riding a
bicycle like you never forget or like
you have to remember eyes all your jokes
like the more easy
the better you are or does it help to
have a lethal break um definitely the
more you do the better than you that you
are but it also probably helps to have a
little break I'm sufficiently wasted 20
minutes and now we can officially dive
in to the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay we
actually have some very good stories
today fallacious I believe here juicy
and no offense but like this okay sorry
I want to talk about one more thing this
week was scrounging for stories oh okay
I watched happily ever after Oh Taylor
Strucker watched it too and she was
talking about it on the show yesterday
okay I [ __ ] soul of Sanaa Lathan and I
watched and I need you to know that she
is not the girl who bit Beyonce there
was a lot of speculation but for my very
legitimate sources it was not her to
marry him so no until I have another
name okay but soon I was very like very
upset that people thought it was her
from what I understand it was not her
okay just saying I appreciate you I
absolutely love her she's in the affair
and in the affair she had a shaved head
and I was like oh wonder why she did
that
and she really shaved her head for this
movie and the whole movies about hair
and the scene where she's shaving her
head it was shot once and it's really
when she shaved her head and it was the
best some of the best acting I've ever
seen in my life and I did have a couple
issues with the movie because her
character in the beginning is like
perfect and like when she's perfect
she's so unbelievably annoying but like
gorgeous and then when she just kind of
like lets go she like puzzle over this
guy and the guy is like so not the right
guy for her he's such a weirdo and like
gross plants in his house and like it's
like rubbing a serum on her bald head
like I'm not into this guy
her first guy was so cute and like I
really loved her but then when he told
her straighten her hair and that was
like not cool but I just didn't like the
guy that she ended up with it's like she
didn't need to end up with anyone like
the whole movie because she's ending up
with herself right yeah and she was
really falling in love with herself the
whole movie and I thought that they were
gonna take that turn and be like no
she's not gonna get with any of them
like it's her life she's gonna do what
she wants to do no she got with the bad
guy and then her parents like who he
didn't hated each other the whole movie
like jumped in the pool together and
then like forgot about literally their
thirty-year treacherous divorce it was
that part was like so stupid they lost
me at the end but up until then I was
there okay I'm living for Netflix
original movies like just available on
demand it's like they know which ones I
want to watch because every time I go to
Netflix to watch friends for the
hundredth time it's just right there I'm
like yeah I guess I'll try no they you
know what what
- buzzin yeah so okay I'll check out
it's really good first story speaking of
relationships that aren't coming well
JWoww files for divorce from husband
Roger Matthews after three years of
marriage JWoww and her husband Roger
Matthews are splitting up the Jersey
Shore star whose real name is Jenny
Farley filed for divorce in Ocean County
New Jersey two weeks ago according to
the Asbury Park Press the 32 year old
cited irreconcilable irreconcilable
differences
and claims their relationship has been
rocky for at least six months quote the
plaintiff and the defendant have
irreconcilable don't make exciting
irreconcilable
irreconcilable differences which have
caused the breakdown of the marriage for
a period of at least six months which
make it appear that the marriage should
be dissolved and that there is no
prospect of reconciliation parlays
complaint said according to the website
but according to Rogers mr. and J
Instagram he is going to reconcile with
her no matter what it takes I can't lie
I was like so absolutely devastated when
I heard this and I saw it first at a
very legitimate news source and I was
gonna put it on the toast and then I was
like you know what a pee-pee calm is not
a real story yes I went through the
exact same thing and I kept googling cuz
I was like if they picked it up this is
in like a local
TMZ will pick it up - I literally just
kept refreshing refreshing and I'm like
this is fake news yeah but ask Barry
Park press he's the one who cited well
here's the thing it's like I feel a
particular way about jenni and Roger for
so many reasons one because I just find
their Instagram to be so funny and like
really genuine and like he's really like
obviously like I'm very like committed
dad and I just like love that but also
always I kept it so real right and like
we were so there for a part when Jersey
Shore was coming like in its heyday like
it wasn't like fake scripted shows that
they are now like it was so real and
that's why it was so popular and like
the way him and jenni fell in love was
like a little shady cuz she like had
that boyfriend who was so mean turned
stole her hard drive but it's insane and
still to watch yeah oh my god look that
she's like it hasn't a job see this and
then like Snooki's hugging her from
behind like epic but like and then Roger
was saying that you are waiting for her
for her to start her new life and she
ran back and like really like it was
like a fit of Jersey Shore fairytale and
I just under rated one at that yes
because they save consistent they were
like till the show ended it was just
them she was never like whoring it up
like they were just good and solid and
you never had to worry about them and I
just like fell in love with their love
story and I just lived
we been like involved in their like life
because I followed both of them on
Instagram and I'm just like so sad about
this I'm so sad too but watching Rogers
he posted a video saying like he's gonna
get his wife back like there was no
cheating we're leavin you Roger they got
into like a cycle of bad habits that
they just continued to repeat so it
needed to break the cycle right unless
there's something like bad going on that
we don't know and when you hear bad
habits like you obviously think like the
obvious thing but if there's no nothing
bad going on like Pete like when you
have kids and like when you have jobs
like sometimes like you just don't have
time for your marriage and it takes
something like this to like really
re-evaluate and I really hope that they
can get back together if it's the
healthy thing to do I agree and their
kids are so key I'm rooting for them
both separately and together but you
know what now I'm like I'm thinking like
do you think it has something to do with
like their newfound fame cuz like yes
the Jersey Shore cast like has always
been famous but like before the revamp
they were just like regular folk with
like kids who had like extra money and
like more than their neighbors but also
like a couple people knew who they were
in like kind of million Instagram
followers now they're like really
launched into stardom and like relevancy
yes but I think back in the heyday they
were like really really in it and it was
so new that they didn't know how to
handle it so if the two of them got
through that this is a piece of cake
they have stable lives they have two
they have homes now they're just making
extra money and more Instagram followers
but I think they they all are in a
better place like more grounded did you
see what did you see I had another
thought and it replaced my thought hold
on was it about Jersey Shore yeah well
obviously but what I was gonna say that
replaces my original thought is joey
camasta is co-hosting with me on october
8th or 9th when you're not here and it
will get all the scoop okay maybe he
knows something that we don't know and
the second thing I was gonna say oh do
you remember when still he and JWoww had
that show Snooki and JWoww and like the
floor then fire fire Jonas style right
like up a staircase yes that was so
funny and epic like and by the way after
Jersey Shore MTV tried so hard to make
that shot but like they gave Benny and
his mom their own show which was like
funny like a Lil Jon came to his house
for dinner and then they also made
Stuckey and JWoww and I wonder if we're
gonna see any more sort of spin-offs
from this new I wouldn't even I wouldn't
be surprised if we got a situation and
fiance wedding special totally um maybe
I'll be getting nothing
Pauly D should have
so his life is so interesting right he
actually has like a job in life and
money yeah what did I watch on him that
like followed him around oh no it was a
complex uh complex profiles the most
interesting people like they have a good
Jew ever selecting them is great
remember when they did the Jax Taylor
one yes member when they did Heidi and
Spencer before Spencer snapchat and
Brett surgeons yeah no they just choose
interesting people like that I care
about so thank you for doing it for me
and they popularized the like homeboy
can like get it yeah they really they
don't get enough credit for that cuz
that video was there's there's a sneaker
video with Bella and like and they like
got that nugget like it I hadn't seen
just that one I've never what do I would
watch the whole video right look if
homeboy is coming through
homeboy can like get it he better be
fresh with joke kicks you know I love
cupcakes
okay if I ever started like a sneaker
Instagram it would be called dope kicks
or homeboy can like get it cakes with no
job yeah there was no job okay this next
story is really for you and then Leah
Remini claims Katie Holmes kuboos
daughter if they reconnect
I'm sure Remini claims her old friend
Katie Holmes could lose their daughter
if they repair their broken friendship
quote I thought comedy would be my life
remedy and ex-scientologists and woman
behind the A&E show Scientology in the
aftermath told the pom magazine but are
you sure Claudio sure girl home jobs
didn't say that
I thought comedy would be my life no but
company is your life she's not like she
didn't get to be king of queens as well
better watch out there Kevin James I've
seen like he's such a truck driver and
she's his wife and it took me so long to
figure out it's the king of Queen
because they live in Queens it's not a
show about cards the people who speak on
the show are champions then she goes
into her former friendship with Tom
Cruise's third ex-wife but I keep
wondering why haven't Katie Holmes er
Nicole Kidman spoken out the 48 year old
question actress questioned I assume
they were forced to sign prohibitive
documents trust me Katie's not allowed
to have a meal with me and we used to be
close friends she could lose custody of
Surrey it's quite sick really right
that's why Nicole Kidman doesn't talk to
their her children with Tom Cruise
because she's considered she's shunned
no it's an SP it's a separated person
that's what they call you when you leave
Scientology yeah um and I guess the kids
are still very involved in that's what
in his song Keith Urban what kind of man
blue ain't your color yeah and what kind
of man takes a kids and turns them
ice cold it's all very crazy but what's
also crazy is that Katie Holmes like got
custody of Surrey right and what's also
Crazy's like she's literally been having
a secret relationship with Jamie Foxx
for years and they've never are allowed
to be seen in public together because of
what tunku terms can do it's like she
wants me famous so bad that she signed
this document that literary she hands it
over a good life her career her future
children grandchildren just because she
wanted to be in like Dawson's Creek I
don't even know what she was in oh sorry
first daughter no know what's where
Steve Martin's her dad uh first daughter
Princess Bride I don't know I don't know
I never saw Prince well actually I saw
the beginning but then those little
animals that came out of the tunnel
I was out but you know it is it's like
she's like so famous like she is like a
less recognized ability and her name is
like what the hell is she in uh well
that I really think came from Tom's
quarters so what's it worth that Katie
know was it by the way the Church of
Scientology responded in a statement
they said while we would prefer to
ignore yet another of Leah Remini
over-the-top rants aimed at getting
attention she unfortunately continues to
incite waves of anti religious hate
crimes ok can you imagine it's like just
for a second like the chief rabbi of
Judaism or like the the Pope releasing a
statement about like what some no
offense like I love her like b-list
celebrity says like they're upset about
your religion like at the same time like
how weird is it that like Scientology is
I don't believe like I know what it is
but like it is considered in this
country to be a religion like they don't
pay taxes like it's a full religion and
the way people speak about it is like so
derogatory that like a magic they spoke
about that like any other religion you
know no it's really crazy but I guess
because they can't see what we're saying
right right right um right so I said ok
but this guy saw yeah I mean they the
Scientology like upper level like they
all have cell phones and like are on
snapchat and [ __ ] because they have the
TV station yeah oh right they have to
find all the people that are talking
[ __ ] about them so that they can kill
them in their sleep duh can't do that
without a phone speaking of killing
people in their sleep we're recording a
podcast with an T later today oh my god
totally so me and Jackie were just like
I feel like we really shot our load and
the first time we spoke to him cuz like
we had like a rat we rattled off a
billion years worth of questions from
reading NT every day since Olivia
introduces right so now I want to be
like a little bit more specific with
like certain cases so if you have any
suggestions tweet them at us because
we're talking to him at one o'clock
what is our release
plan for that so it is a patreon episode
because I'm just so like I don't want
any trouble we need to be hidden away
scot-free with the first episode we're
gonna get into the nitty gritty we're
going behind a paywall much like NT does
himself and you know what it's smart
right now I know why n T's on patreon
well like one cuz II just make a living
with two because like if he's not like
it's just out there for like all the
Predators to here and then like tell
their their hit men that jay-z hired to
try and kill Rihanna I'm sure to me
about that yes so it will be a patron
episode we're recording another patreon
episode afterwards he went over to today
so that'll go up today and then the NTFS
ode will be the first episode of October
so maybe should have just booked two
hours in the studio like twelve whatever
we did I mean we'll see if it's
available well no it's not because I
know someone's asked in there too okay
so we can do the center own um
patreon.com/scishow morning toast we'll
see you there and then I still need to
do my home tour I keep my knee but I
like bought all these flowers to make it
like nice for my tour which I never did
my home is slowly deteriorating and it's
probably what's now been good yeah no I
mean I'm like so invested in the things
that I can fix like because we have this
like overflow toilet flood it's like
there's a lot of issues like you can't
see but so I can't get in there and fix
it which is so infuriating so I'm get
like I'm doing other things like my
bedrooms almost on my carpet which is a
Jill Zarin rug it's coming I've heard
amazing things and I texted Ally I'm
like can you please get me when she said
yeah of course so I'm excited to say
theö on Tuesday I saw your [ __ ] up
floors it was crazy
and when you because apparently I didn't
even know this like if there's a flood
you obviously have to get the water out
and we had it vacuums like with one of
those machines but you can't get all you
can't guarantee that you get all the
water out from underneath at the floor
like the wood planks and if you leave it
there it starts to bubble and literally
my floor just started like cracking open
it was so crazy like a manhole that's so
crazy cuz you're building so nice and I
didn't tell you this but it was like
really hurtful because when I went to
pick up Theo like I definitely didn't
look my best you know I walked up there
because it was UN week and I just didn't
want to be sitting in traffic and your
doorman made me take the service
entrance what did you tell me my sister
like no I was just like I'm here and
like I'm going up to bla bla bla like
I'm taking the dog and oh my god Jackie
with a dog walker maybe it's cuz you
never come over if snitch comes they
just let her right up you know I think
it's just cuz you have to act like you
know it's not it's not
yes ready because I have a thing on my
door it says any of my sisters and I
wrote all the names are allowed to just
come and take the key whenever they want
okay well next time I'll come with more
Chevy they thought you were the dog
walker well I didn't know like they knew
if you weren't home like what am i doing
just I don't know I don't know Margo
does it all the time I've never even
been in the service Ellie or camel you
have there so I went up in it and then I
was waiting for it with Theo and it was
heaving so long I'm like [ __ ] it it's
like we're taking the peoples out later
I can't believe my end for that in a
huff I mean that's just the confidence I
have I don't have when I'm not wearing
me no that's just how like anti
confrontation yours I didn't
conversation you just been I'm her
sister you may use nted yourself like as
if you were the dog walker I didn't know
we talked about gonna have to get the
service entrance they're so weird about
the service elevator in my building it's
like just let everyone take us in I
order it was so hurtful I hadn't thought
about it till now I tried to suppress
the memory well I really just started
sweating I got hot in here I'm always
sweating okay next story
she works hard money so um those were
some nice snaps mm-hmm next story
Arianna there are people who can't stand
I mean can you stop in your left hand
like I can but like look right it hurt
right hand left hand
oh pretty good do you want to hear see a
really cool trick that I learned
Shoreham Cece Johnson when I was picking
out invitations for my wedding so you
know sometimes you high-five someone and
like it doesn't go your way if you stare
at their elbow and I stare at yours yeah
you will will knock it out of the park
learn them in summer camp really I never
heard it before
nice uh top things you learned on the
morning toast
okay next story ariana grande ariana
grande ariana grande Grande reflects on
tough month an emotional twitter plate
emotional and a little concerning yeah
Ariana Grande is asking the universe to
give her a break on Thursday the song
just went on Twitter at events some of
the emotions she has been feeling in the
wake of Mac Miller's death in one tweet
she asks can I please have one okay day
just one please she continued I'm so
tired please Ariana then retweeted one
of her old tweets where she wrote
everything will be okay and replied just
[ __ ]
J [ __ ] K Oh like just kidding kidding
in the midst of her cryptic messages
fans flooded her Twitter with messages
of support and adoration this seemingly
prompted up Grande to thank her fans for
loving her so much even though she says
quote I don't deserve it
well no the most concerning ones were
like I'm so tired I just want to go to
sleep I just I feel so like badly for
her she's been through so much in her
life and like I know I mean I don't know
I even come back from her whole
situation in Manchester like I can't
even begin to think of what kind of
feelings that makes you have and she did
in a way that was like super authentic
and like unique and like really special
in like didn't like she she continues to
like honor the victims of the Manchester
bombing like in different unique special
ways and like to that to me that just
proves like a strong person in general
and like just a being in the spotlight
as much as much as she is like can't
always be the easiest thing and like now
people saying the most horrible
disgusting things that like it's her
fault that Mac Miller killed himself
like are you kidding also it's like Mac
Miller was the one who was really there
for her after Manchester right like and
it seemed like they were still good
friends she's looking after his dog
right um and then I saw like the same
person in such a sad way and I know
they're like more sad elements than this
but like the dog is like where's Mac you
know oh my god that makes me so sad to
think about that's like if a dog's owner
dies they just like where's the owner
anything this should be like what number
that happiest times in her life after
going through so much and it's like she
can't even enjoy like her engagement you
know what this gives me like Bethany
vibes like some people who just can't
catch a break you know but like Bethany
went through a divorce like she's going
through of course she was Bethany went
through like human problems like wasn't
sure is extraordinary like most people
in life will never have to deal with
like the a third of the amount problem I
was like putting on a concert your
people are murdered and I would like and
the feelings associated with that
totally unfortunately more people are
dealing with that right very sad very
sad and like I don't know those I was
how I saw those Twitter tweets in real
time because I was like on Twitter and
they were just like like a red flag vibe
you know like when I just want to go to
sleep what does that mean I don't know
but like I'm so tired you have a few
days off like what is she doing that
can't be no she does she literally she's
off but like she what she's saying is
like I guess like you're kept up at
night just like by these fears and these
thoughts that like I just want to go to
sleep like I know what she means yeah
like you're so caught up that you
literally can't even sleep which I
actually have the opposite effect like I
was telling Margo like when I feel so
scared and like so whatever like my
immediate reaction is I could fall
asleep in two seconds like on an
airplane when I think I'm gonna die like
in the two situations that I've been in
where I've been like serious issue like
emergency like people with a whipping
out their Bibles and stuff I've fallen
asleep that's my thing that is a gift
I know chair and then I woke up and it
was over I feel like we just I don't
know what we can do for Arianna granny
but I just wanna like be there for her
and I feel like there's so many people
that feel that way because if you read
her Twitter like replies it's everyone's
like we're here we're here we're here
and I feel like at some point it's like
it's nobody can help what she needs I
don't even know right I mean there's
also the people who are like blaming her
for Mac Miller's death what she needs
honestly is to get off of Twitter yeah
it's the worst place in the world yeah
like all the platforms are terrible but
that one in particular is discussed
ariana grande does not need to hear what
people think about her like she is on a
whole nother level like except if you
want to hear what we think about you we
think you're great we love you we love
you and we just want the best for you
and you got you to be happy but we also
understand you're going through and I'm
like not to be shady or anything but I
just don't feel like Pete Davidson is
like the greatest person to like lean on
in times of grief you know I actually
disagree
he's been why cause he's a co me know
and his dad passed away 9/11 and I think
he's gotten through so much and it's
like it's interesting that you say that
cuz you don't even associate him with
the drama that you enter because he's so
good at handling it and also like in
every moment of sadness like it is good
to laugh so I guess having a very famous
comedian around you can't be bad and
that must be how you guys feel oh yes
it's definitely how we feel and so if
anyone can maybe understand like what
she's going through losing someone so
close to her so sudden and like a tragic
way yeah and how to overcome that I feel
like she's actually in ok yeah that's
interesting I agree you've changed my
mind and I'm here for them that never
happens I'm usually just either if we
don't disagree if we don't agree which
is like never we'll just like agree to
disagree but you should you mind happy
to hear it
anyways like as much as I like talking
about you I like talking at them and I
don't I feel like the more we talk about
like more hurryings like the more of the
world we're contributing to those sweeps
right so only when it's big news we
continue to talk about it agreed I think
I think that's that's smart okay next
story in another TZ teaser from next
week's episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim Kardashian says Scott
Disick wants to have another baby with
Kourtney I actually am really here for
this story soon the Kardashian baby boom
might not be over yet in people's
exclusive sneak peak at Sunday's episode
of keeping up Kim reveals that Scott has
been thinking about expanding his family
with ex Kourtney Kardashian they ended
their nine-year relationship in July
2015 and share sons Mason rein and
daughter Penelope well they've been
together for three years
yeah quote so Scott just text me that he
wants to have another baby with Kourtney
Kim tells Larsa Pippen who's getting a
lot more air time this season
congratulation cuz she needs the money
quote I think he just wants one more and
she wants one more she definitely wants
more kids if they both want to have more
kids why not have them together their
kids are gorgeous I come clean okay I
thought Scott would it be down for it
cuz last week Kourtney was like yeah I
want to have one more and obviously I
think it would be just the smarter thing
if they all have the same dad and
because they are so cute and they are
this like family unit and I thought
Scott would like not be down for that
the only person I think we'd have to
convince is like Sophia Richie
well then Kim says I mean it's like
Scott has a girlfriend Courtney has a
boyfriend we get it they don't even have
to have sex it's B IV yeah I completely
agree
and it's like her relationship with
Scott is already like tumultuous
dramatic and it's like but he is the
father of her children so he will always
be in her life why would you want to add
like one more complication complicated
relationship like that like when you
don't have to pull so more kids it's all
the same thing who is Kourtney gonna
have a baby with her and Eunice broke up
and he's also like a child
he's a child too kind of a child and
then she's been seen with this new guy
who honestly like not to be mean it's
just like not cute and like their baby
would be the ugliest
right and even if she couldn't maybe she
would be like oh I would just have a
baby with Eunice or whoever the flavor
of the moment is just because she wants
the other kid but like in that situation
just do it with Scott it it'll keep you
need another complicated baby daddy
relationship no no and it's like you
know at this way they know that they can
trust Scott like you're a team player
he doesn't have families you know I need
another blac chyna situation totally and
just their kids are so cute I'm really
shocked at like cuz as much as like
celebrities have everything and they can
get whatever they want and they can look
however they want like when you have a
kid
like it's born how they're born like you
can't give the kid Botox so I'm just
like endlessly surprised at how cute all
of the kids are like Kim's three kids
like are this perfect unit who like all
look like a perfect mix North is way
more Kim and st. is way more Kanye and
then Chicago we'll see but like they're
this perfect mix they're like the
perfect family just in like the way that
they look like exactly 50 percent mom
dad and their true is so cute and like
I'm just surprised there hasn't been
like one ugly baby you know it was like
I happy honest I really like with all
the girl the daughters and the grandkids
it's really like kris Jenner's jeans are
like posted rep they should like take
her DNA and replicate it because it's
like she gives birth to these like
gorgeous people who also give 3s1 know
that they like don't look now how they
would have naturally but like even if
they were still 40 years old and the
exact like they never touched her faces
they were all beautiful when they were
younger and they would be beautiful now
they're still beautiful they're just
like a little different um no totally
I'm surprised there just hasn't been
like one you know FedEx totally jury's
still out you never know yeah well don't
say okay um and I was like I'm not baby
fish it's 11 love and make a dream but I
did get three Zac Posen bags so you know
what that's pretty good too yeah but you
still wonder get you back of course I
mean no go say no no no no never no um
wait can I say something caught up on
Kardashians anyone talked about oh yeah
because I agreed with everything that
you said you were told obviously because
I because you put it in with your mind -
um and I was watching the Gabbana
episode with you and he was hooked to
the core and I think it just made him
appreciate like the time he doesn't get
teary-eyed at all um no because I was
really focused on Theo he was just like
being right moment when I didn't get
really cheery odd because they all
didn't seem like that upset about it but
when Chloe was just like they were doing
like panther of her house and she was
like I used to hear him in my house all
the time and like now I just hear
silence like oh my god that's my worst
nightmare
no quiet house so sad but two things
that really struck me first of all like
the fact that those three girls had
children like within two months of each
other had three grandchildren within two
months of each other I think it's just
so special and I think that's why
Kourtney's feeling like a little left
for sure and that's
Kourtney and Kendall are like salty on
the side totally and it's like Oh
throughout all like ten years of
Kardashians all they've been saying is
they want their kids to have that
special closeness and like they want to
be close in age like they were growing
or growing up and at certain points you
didn't know if it was gonna happen Mason
is now like alert oh yeah and Nixon has
a job Khloe was married and she couldn't
have children and she really wanted to
get in there it's kismet her kids would
be with me like with Kourtney's kids and
it's like they have that what they
wanted and they're it's like they're
triplets and they like I know everyone
says like they're vain and while they
and they are but like I feel like in
recent years like their priorities have
really shifted and like they're now so
much more like business and family like
that's it and like they're really are
owning and operating like legitimate
businesses like good American is gonna
gross like literally a billion dollars
because they're so sighs inclusive and
they sell in every literally every store
they sell in bloomingdales Nordstrom and
Kylie cosmetics obviously and Kim's
fragrances and all that like and
Kourtney's um nothing no she has Liam
and so I just really feel like their
priorities have shifted to one that I
can really like get behind and relate to
like I to like all I really care about
is like growing the Cho's and spending
time with my family
Toto and I feel like in the beginning of
Kardashians like that's what made it so
lovable it's like they're really a
family then they reach this level of
Fame and as I can was trying to just
like marry Kris Humphries and it became
just like they worked and they were
never together like in the same location
they were like same monsters which I
understand and now it's the reach level
of Fame where it's like they can do
whatever they want they can do what they
want to do like have big families right
and successful businesses and I just
want to say Kourtney is such an [ __ ]
like any scene that she's in even when
she's not being even when she's not in a
fight she's being an [ __ ] North is
such a tomboy really she's like
literally the most girly girl ever and
like you know how much Kim who like he's
like obsessed with like makeup and glam
like that's like and she was just saying
like in a derogatory way that what
really bother me is when they were
sitting at a restaurant and Kim is
talking about what baby names she should
do and Kourtney's being annoying with
bad names and then brings up Reggie Bush
and Ray J and Eunice didn't know Reggie
refused a debate and it's like why are
you bringing that up like if you brought
up like something like that one when I'm
about to have a baby I'm talking about
baby look I know later over ten years
later and like something that
clearly is oh oh sorry [ __ ] that rage a
red J red J made you famous and bought
your house please
we know that Kim wants to move on from
that like why would you bring that up
and also even Reggie it's like Kim I
loved him so much and worked so hard for
him and in a in a different world like
they would have made it like they could
have worked it he was probably like
maybe the one that got away yeah she was
just like too much on their eyes and
could have yet all this football games
and like he really cared about that
stuff and so why would you bring that up
I thought that was like cruel yeah and
Kim just handles it so well yeah she
just like ignores her so anytime
Kourtney like shows up to film it's like
she just wants to like make people feel
bad no but she's not gonna outright be
like I hate you she does like subliminal
things that she knows like she chips
away at things that bother Kim like the
tomboy thing was just like if you know
him at all and like you know North like
first of all like I don't even know
North but I know she's not john-boy like
she's always with the making yeah like
it was just like when she when Pierre
said wait when Kim said that Kylie had
originally asked her to be in the labor
room and Courtney was like oh kylie
needed you or something like that i was
just gonna say that and she was like if
she really needed you you would have
been there and like by the way it was
nice of her to give it to Chloe because
one Khloe and Kylie are really close and
like Chloe should get to see like a
birth up close before her vagina gets
ripped up in by true and also like Chloe
is very hands-on kim's very like
germaphobic yeah Kim knew that wasn't
the place for her and then Kourtney was
like in her interview you know no one
knew about the pregnancy she came so far
I didn't want to be the one with the
burden of the information and it's like
no one asks you yeah no one even
considered you um when you give birth
who's gonna be there oh I've really felt
about this like a hundred times it
depends how big like it depends like
where I'm at in my life and what kind of
suite I can get because if I can get a
big room like I would want everyone
there let's say that's it everyone
combined like on the sidelines like I
don't want you in the end zone you know
what I mean like and I want to be like
hovered like oh give me names um all the
scenes yeah
and Zack yeah yeah you want twins a cup
topper about him
I think up top you know what I mean like
I'm gonna keep the magic alive I should
remain a mystery ya know Steen's but who
knows scenes men yeah yeah and I feel
like I would maybe have like one of you
pull it out
maybe Olivia cuz she would be down
actually I don't know I'm gonna leave it
to the professionals
yeah I definitely want you guys like
there but not in it you know yeah yeah I
mean obviously gonna take like a look
maybe take a big chair just like so you
could see oh my god I don't think you
can't even see the your own birth that's
so scary and I don't think there's a
reason for that if you were meant to see
your own birth leg it would come out of
your belly button yeah I mean it can I
like want to have children and they get
like so excited I've been waiting for it
my whole life but like I do not want to
give birth well yeah but it's then it
happens and then it's over and it's like
you're your vagina like rips open to
your butt like it's literally just one
but yeah and then like things just start
falling out stop like the placenta are
you gonna eat your own placenta god no
no remember when they fake cooked a
placenta yeah that's funny oh my
goodness well at least you're giving
birth in 20 or 2018 2019 2020 as opposed
to like the 1700s oh my god how did they
do it well almost a lot of women died at
childbirth like that doesn't seem like
that was the way it was meant to be you
know if it's meant to be it will be
maybe just let it be no yeah I'm very
grateful I would be taking all the drugs
those psychos who want no drugs like
because they want to feel the pain
that's like nice and all but I'm not
like that give me every single drug and
like the maximum that you can give
legally I'll remember that
epidural the [ __ ] out of me I'll
remember that okay fifth and final story
I've been waiting to get to all day
because it's really the only story that
matters in the toaster universe okay
the SEC sues Elon Musk for his allegedly
misleading tweets you guys this is a big
[ __ ] deal the SEC don't play an empty
doesn't lie cuz we knew about this
writing Elon Musk has tweeted himself
into serious trouble we need to talk to
NT about Lee Thomas query note down the
security hold on what was the other
thing we said wants to talk to him about
um jay-z jay-z and 9023 meets just for
me personally so haven't sent in my
kitchen ez 23andme Emma was one we just
said he won the Securities and Exchange
Commission sued Tesla CEO on Thursday
for making quote false and misleading
statements to investors it's asking a
federal judge to prevent musk
from serving as an officer or a director
of a public company among other
penalties the complaint hinges on a
tweet musk scent on August 7th about
taking Tesla private quote I'm
considering taking Tesla private at $420
musk said funding secured and we
reported that tweet the SEC said he had
not actually secured funding so that was
the misleading part and that's why he's
being sued in like just cuz I get off
Twitter you and Ariana Grande
like just go like but that was it just
cuz the tweet that's what the intrusion
in fact must cannot even discuss much
less confirmed keeled terms including
price with any potential funding source
the SEC said in his complaint that tweet
and subsequent tweets form us over the
next three hours caused quote
significant confusion Oh and disruption
in the market for Tesla's stock as well
as harm to investors the SEC said on the
day of Musk's tweet toss Tesla's stock
shot up nearly 9% it is declined
substantially since then
Tesla's stock dropped more than 11% and
after-hours trading on Thursday but
here's the thing it's like there he's
being sued he should either be if it's
illegal he should technically be
arrested and if he caused some sort of
disruption he should be like find yeah
not sued because if you see you go to
court and there's a chance that you
don't win no but um I think but you
don't win then you get fined like they
have to go to play he can't just stop a
fine about proving that he did something
wrong but I got ik
honestly like it's the rise and fall of
Elon Musk has been wild because like for
a period in time like when we started to
talk about him when we thought he was
Julian Assange we were confused but like
he and Edward Snowden we're doing
differently like he was the most
respected revered mind of our time like
there wasn't anyone in this world who
didn't like appreciate and just like but
he got to in it and he became to
celebrity and he obviously fell into the
disgust of Hollywood and like he's
obviously now like addicted to drugs and
can't stop tweeting while he's on acid
according to his Elia banks so like but
what I've heard is that people who work
at SpaceX like are not worried at all
and like right over there right and I
and I do think that it's fine but maybe
like because he is such a creative like
maybe he shouldn't be like the CEO
I always that's what they see on shark
tank you're either the inventor they or
the entrepreneur like you're the
business part or the brainy like making
gears and [ __ ] but you know what like
say your thing there's not one person in
the world not even Elon Musk who can do
both no there's definitely some up
someone in the world you can't it's not
it's not Ilana look at us we're the
creators that's true that's true but
we're not like Elon Musk is not one of
those people you don't have to be one of
the other okay but it's very rare to be
both and I don't think that I think Elon
Musk is really like the mind of the
genius of our time and should have
stayed like the mind and let someone
else take over like the business and
like the front-facing like commerce side
of that well now he should have someone
do that just to like safe
Ilan I just want you to know I still
believe in you and I I I believe in you
I mean I'm like getting over it I used
to go to bat for him like I did Bethenny
and I was like an Elon apologist um but
like now I'm kind of over him and he's
like doing things that like I really
can't support anymore he's yet to do
anything where I'm going to turn on him
completely just because of like I think
of all the good that he can do in the
world yeah
SpaceX but lucky for loop if that
Taiwanese even if the Thai Navy whatever
seafarin Unsworth Verne Unsworth it
turns out to be a pedophile that maybe
I'll turn it back around but like a part
of me just doesn't think that he is
right and he's being sued now never just
said something mean to someone cuz they
hurt your feelings course it wasn't true
of course it's been a LAN tweeted like
no he is like he substantiated his claim
oh maybe it's true that yeah but notice
until proven suing Elon so if it is true
he lands gonna have to prove it and then
right not libel but in this moment he's
innocent because he just gets been
proven guilty
this is trail what else not much else
it's been a quiet week it really has
because I was I've been a long week and
I'm really glad the week is over me it -
what are you doing this weekend um with
my family what I want to do nothing like
I really want to do nothing
I had a treacherous week even though
like when you break it up with Jose like
it does feel the week feels short of
like it breaks up the week but it's just
a longer week like last weekend feels
like forever ago wait let's talk about
next week because next week I have some
I have a good line up on deck because
you're here Monday Tuesday when wind so
I wait Monday is October 1st and we also
have Anthony Vasquez so we will be I've
already decided we are calling
lin-manuel well hopefully he picks up
we're gonna call from your phone cuz he
definitely doesn't I'm your phone number
and we're gonna put a mic by the phone
or whatever the best way is and we're
just gonna to commemorate the
anniversary of October 1st I recent I
watch that episode because the one where
he tell the story too because I got a
shared in the toasters and I was dying
laughing I know and I looks like it
looked cute that day and I like now it's
like I'm glad that that's video keeps me
servicing because sometimes from when we
used to sit in those chairs on the
breath like my chin was so bad and so
that was a particularly good video so
I'm like happy about it we and there was
something
that I'd like didn't even make me laugh
so hard at the time but made me laugh so
hard and I was like wouldn't you
initially oh it's like [ __ ] well when
you're like his lin-manuel Miranda but
then we should clip it and put it on the
Instagram because we have a lot of new
toasters they may not be aware of the
particular importance of October first
it's a very important day and we have
Anthony Vasquez who's gonna be sharing
so many fun memories from your
anniversary and he's gonna share some
exclusive photos from my wedding because
I've yet to sit down with him and like
do the thing I was supposed to do for my
books so him being here will just be
like get me like leggy to fire under my
ass yes and then next week I'm actually
going with him to Dallas so right there
to take my previous Tuesday is just us
Tuesday's just that's normal show
Wednesday we are we going early on
Wednesday no okay
Wednesday same time we have Astrid and
Kevin from bachelor in paradise and then
I'm being whisked off to Buffalo for two
shows and then Albany tickets available
at girl with no job comment very excited
to see you all there Thursday Android my
Heather McMann you guys can use down
harassing her I'm so excited I'm gonna
find out who the girls on the plane she
was talking about where when I see this
oh my god so she was on the plane from
New York to Atlanta and there were two
girls sitting next to her that like
looks like young teens and they're like
talking [ __ ] the whole time so loudly
and it turns out like they're one at
least one of them is an actor she's
going to Atlanta to film this new show
and she's talking [ __ ] about the lead
actress on the show like we would never
be friends in real life blah blah blah
there was someone for Heather looked up
who like what show who's the lead
actress valley actress has like very
famous parents she was like why would
she be talking like this she was like
such an [ __ ]
they're jeweling on the plane in their
shirts and Heather like won't tell
anyone who it is but if any checking it
but if it's um it's not time to ste oh
[ __ ] that's what it was it's a new show
that has like and a lot most shows do
you film in Atlanta cuz it's a lot
cheaper I had a theory but I don't think
it's a theory
my theory was that the the famous person
the lead actress that they're talking
[ __ ] about who um has same as parents
was Maude Apatow yeah and then I was
like what is moderato filming she's
filming a new show for HBO that is
slated to be a hit because one it's on
HBO and two it's based off an Israeli
show that like does well already then
there are all these like extra actors a
couple of likes thirsty girls who would
be talking [ __ ] about Maude
Jakub awardees in it but I can't figure
out where it's filming but I also don't
think it's her anymore why um I forget
and also the way I came about it was
just such a hunch I was watching her I
was looking at Leslie Mann I was like
wow powerful famous woman I hit the
daughter who acts
I love Leslie Mann and I love the JED up
to how cuz he makes amazing movies and
he always puts his wife at the star
which is just like if I ever married a
director like you'd have to do the same
thing um and you know what well they're
just like and they always play annoying
characters maybe that's what it is the
younger one is cute and I like her and
she hasn't started to annoy me yet but
the older one who was in girls well
that's my thing it's like you could do
anything that you want in this world and
for the most part she's like done really
cool stuff except like she interned for
Harvey Weinstein and that was like not
good right and it was before everything
came out but like people everyone in the
chat like why would you choose Miramax
same with Malia Obama yeah why would
anyone confused I don't know if I'm on
Apatow oh maybe I confused no Obama did
okay did I think I confuse them but it's
like you can do anything that you want
and you choose for like a cameo long
girls like I just can't relate to and
not even like first season girls like
fourth season girls like when they're
the kids and this is 40 very cute
annoying oh the younger brothers cute
the one younger one is cute they have
weird names to Maude what's the other
ones iris I always think her name's mom
but look that color because I was just
googling her I know that's Maude Maude
yeah is it nice to make fun of people's
names or is that like a mean thing now I
feel like you can't make fun of anyone
anymore which is nice I guess but like
but you should go to more comedy shows
because it's so funny the way that they
like make fun of people and they talk
about like the slack that they get like
there was an opener for Kevin Hart who
is he went there wasn't oh I forgot his
name I'll have to look there were a
bunch of openers like getting the crowd
revved up and there was one guy all
those features being so funny about a
lot of stuff and he was like talking
about last time they went on tour like
he got in a lot of trouble with the
transgender community and he was like
all I said was that Caitlyn Caitlyn
Jenner is too old to be naming herself
Caitlyn like you are Blanche right
totally
seven years old yourself yeah like there
are no seven year old into name Caitlyn
that is such a great it was oh and I
guess the transgender community was up
in arms but it was so funny and then
Kevin Hart was telling was talking about
his daughter saying that she's a tomboy
like she's a
time we like she takes no shape on the
button and he was like can I still say
tomboy I don't know so funny it's like
so watching comedians like navigate this
new culture makes them actually funnier
yeah sometimes yeah well there's still
like a space in comedy for like that
completely irreverent and like they
disregard like I might as well be like
1990 which is like refreshing but like
now as someone who's like very conscious
of that I'm like and that's like how I
feel when I watch curb right no but then
like one of the acts was like making fun
of like every single race at one point
but he went through every single one so
it's not racist if you're making fun of
everyone right no it's like if you're
including yourself you have like it's
it's almost fair game
yeah I don't know it's sunny I just feel
like is it a are you able is anyone able
to be funny
without being mean or like a little
racist every I'm just thinking of every
comedy show under comedy special I've
ever written about is either like poking
fun at people or at people's like
nationality you know what about Jim
Gaffigan well that's why he's the clean
comment Cooper for him for the Pope did
you know that yes
he's only can you imagine Kevin Hart
like me talk about my hand jobs like
talking the poker or AK revenge in a
Wallace same thing but like I just think
that is such an impressive statistic and
I'm just like endlessly impressed with
Jim Gaffigan and his whole career and I
only want good things for him but if you
were like Claude we're gonna have you
perform for the Pope you were just you
would become a cleaner comment but they
would never ask like me I mean I've
relatively speaking to other female
comics like I'm like PG like they're
always like dick like the one time I
like hard Michelle wolf uh was that her
yeah we it was just like dick [ __ ] you
know and look for the most part mine is
just like talking about how fat I am the
whole [ __ ] the whole show there's like a
couple like you know butthole jokes but
like you know who isn't but so I'm
relatively clean I think yeah look cuz I
just like is that dirty I don't know not
in this world where it's like people
talk about the craziest things yeah no I
mean I've heard some wild [ __ ] it's
funny though yeah kids um okay we were
about to end at exactly 11:30 we have
not ended at 11:30 since our final show
at the breath cuz they used to kick us
out at 11:30 ain't true and now we go
so long and I I'm assuming everyone
likes a really long episodes Lorna Cho
said she loves Emily because they get
her through the day and it's like now
you're closer to lunchtime you're
welcome yeah um but they are really long
I know yesterday's episode was really
long so I was confused by the clock the
whole time and I thought we were only at
45 minutes when we were at an hour and
15 so I kept going for 15 more minutes
for an hour and a half episode no that's
good well I worked her to the but if you
haven't seen yesterday's episode you can
skip the last 15 minutes is basically
the Jackie's day thank you guys so much
for following not following for tuning
in today the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube and Facebook tickets are
available to my shows in Albany and
Buffalo this week so make sure to head
over to grow boat job comm and get your
tickets before they're sold out thanks
anything you want to shove dumb people
serve I mean you can always follow me on
takeo problems for a premium ask content
and patreon.com slash the morning toast
we're spending the whole weekend
creating premium content we have empty
episode that we're recording today we
have our Q&A part 2 if you're not in the
toast after dark leave your questions
there and then my home tour is coming up
before my flowers die bye guys have a
good weekend
you